[Musique]
boulevard saint-joseph à roberval
quelques jeunes profitent du beau temps
l'élection les intéresse ils devraient
aller voter mike gauthier pour les
libéraux moi je me demande qu'on
changerait si on n'attend pas qu'on peut
avoir dans la lune changer pour changer
on expose ses trois amis eux pensent
voter pour la cac
brandon dallaire m que la caq veuille
favoriser l'embauché de professionnels
dans les écoles un portail de la moitié
des jeunes d'aller à l'école qui font
pas et des phares del potro pour le
futur c'est pas mal et beaucoup faire
d'autre
et surtout ils veulent du changement
changer de parti après un certain temps
c'est nécessaire pour pâques un parti
s'ancre danser danser et qui sont peu
c'est pas que vous détestez monsieur
aucunement c'est vraiment que je trouve
ça normal dans votre changement
monsieur legault et son caniche son
énergie comparer monsieur guillard
tpg je trouve ça un peu dur
je fais les pouilles à cilic ou iard
fait campagne dans son comté de roberval
à la dernière élection il avait été élu
avec 55% des voix selon lui roberval a
été choyé parce qu'il est premier
ministre
250 millions d'investissements publics
lors du dernier mandat
mais je vous dis bien franchement bien
directement comment je sais que bell et
de aussi qu'on a réussi qui aurait pas
réussi c'est le député de roberval
n'était pas pu esquiver jeudi
directement philippe couillard affirme
avoir fait déverser un torrent de
dollars d'un compte et un nouveau pont
pour traverser la rivière mistassini 56
millions 62 millions pour agrandir le
palais de justice de roberval
modernisation du zoo sauvage de
saint-félicien 26 millions des ours
polaires
aux poulains chocolat près de huit cent
mille dollars pour la modernisation de
la chocolaterie des pères trappistes de
mistassini
un investissement qui sert l'entreprise
et ses employés est une sécurité
d'emploi c'est du travail qui est un peu
plus facile parce que les équipements
sont plus modernes
ça donne plus de semaines de travail par
année pour les employés cm2 l'asphalt du
béton des dollars à l'appel et dans ce
domaine de la santé
non le comté n'aurait pas été épargné
par les réductions budgétaires
selon les syndicats les listes
d'attentes dans roberval s'allonge
certains secteurs de son domicile ont
fait face à des augmentations dans la
dernière année de 25 % de cas de
personnes qui attendent sur la liste
d'attentes réflexion sur le perron de
sympathisant libéral de 79 ans né à
saint félicien est ce qu'un match est
plié en aparté grondin dans la place et
dans la comté il dit aux électeurs
pensez-y c'est pas demain la veille
qu'on reverra un député premier ministre
dans roberval c'est pour ça qu'il faut
faire attention aux parfums direction et
bien voter c'est ce qu'on a comme vision
d'avenir mais c'est le retour du
duplessisme répond le candidat de québec
solidaire
je m'excuse mais dans l'histoire du
comté roberval y en eu des choses qui se
sont fait malgré le fait qu'on n'ait pas
eu de premier ministre qui on n'a pas
besoin d'attendre après personne pour se
développer
le candidat du parti québécois dit que
ça peut être vrai qu'il y a des
avantages à avoir député premier
ministre sauf que premier ministre c'est
pas souvent notre compte et c'est
vraiment ce qui a manqué dans la
circonscription de roberval c'est une
écoute de la part de députés
c'est ça qu'on veut donner
et si la cac devait la porter dans
roberval ce serait de nice trudel qui
aurait cet honneur singulier d'avoir
battu premier ministre elle rencontre
les maires du comté ici le maire de
saint-félicien
denise trudel a déjà été député de la
caq dans charlesbourg et conseillère
municipale à québec ce qui est vraiment
payant que ce soit pour n'importe quel
côté peu importe qu'on soit ministre
qu'on soit premier ministre
l'important c'est qu'on soit aiguë
france et lui qu'on soit là pour la
population que ce sera philippe
couillard le soir du vote
candidat défait simple député ou alors à
nouveau premier ministre
les jeux ne sont pas faits on sera le
1er octobre seulement sur quelle branche
les électeurs de roberval ont décidé de
se poser